these are the scientists who've given
the UK a crucial Edge during the
pandemic and these are the devices they
use to sequence the genetic code of
millions of our covid test swabs
now they want to take what they learn
from covid and apply it to other
dangerous respiratory viruses like flu
which are now putting so much pressure
on the NHS we have very limited
understanding about the transmission of
these viruses about their long-term
Evolution about you know how do they do
we see waves in the same way as we do
with coronaviruses so by understanding
more about their biology we hope that we
can help other scientists develop
vaccines develop new treatments but also
think about how we can intervene to
prevent their spread
foreign
the project doesn't start in the lab but
in three refrigerated shipping
containers in the car park it's really
cold in here minus 20 degrees but that's
crucial to keep what they're storing
fresh these boxes contain millions of
samples left over from the covid testing
campaign but there's still a really
valuable resource because of all the
other viruses they might contain
the plan is to design a test to detect
all the other respiratory viruses people
were carrying when they were swapped for
covid and use that to create a new
surveillance program for more routine
infections
something that could take huge pressure
off the Health Service it was covered
that I think made everybody sit up and
realize that actually
the methodology that we've got for
conventional diagnosis conventional
surveillance in the big infectious
diseases is probably been now
surpassed by our ability to do things
with genomics but says Professor Bell
the nhs's ability to innovate and adapt
could be held back by the pressure it's
under it's really difficult to sit up
and say oh gosh this is a new way of
doing things why don't we do it that way
when you're really under so much
pressure in the clinic in the primary
care facilities in the hospitals
kovid may have taught us how new
technology can support Public Health but
it also revealed how vulnerable our
health systems can be and there's no
quick fix for that Tom Clark Sky News